like
yeah today many came here to let out
their emotions
thinking of toddlers targeted by a man
who brought a knife to a playground and
started stabbing those he found
[Music]
this to contend with a remarkably Brave
man who brandished his backpack as a
shield to fend off further violence his
name is enri a 24 year old who was
visiting anesee to see the cathedral
he's no longer just a tourist he's a
hero
um
thankfully the four infants and two
pensioners who were attacked are all in
a stable condition
some of them were visited in hospital by
president macron
he also met with police officers who
were on the scene and of course the
pilgrim turned man of the hour
Colleen Simone's granddaughter attends
the school opposite the playground that
was targeted when she heard the news of
the attack she feared her grandchild was
involved
music
foreign
the suspect has been named as Abdul
Massey H by French media a 31 year old
Syrian refugee who's been living in
Europe for a decade
we've spoken to people here who say they
saw the suspect in the months and even
days leading up to the attack sitting on
this bench near the playground looking
completely calm
Witnesses also say he was homeless is
[Music]
terrorism is not thought to be a motive
for this attack this is a senseless
crime the violence and vulnerability of
the victims Beyond any reason or
understanding Becky cultural Sky News
anicy